On my labs, my fasting glucose is 75. Why would my hemoglobin A1C be 5.2? And my insulin
would be 2.8. Not lab high, but higher scale. Or is the hemoglobin A1C close to normal
seems a bit high, but not sure. I have followed this test before. So you can change your blood
glucose levels quite quickly compared to you being able to change your hemoglobin A1C levels.
That's why really a better look at a person's blood picture for diabetes is hemoglobin A1C.
Because you could get, you know, false low glucose levels, because
person with diabetes or hypoglycemia issues, or in that range where your prediabetic
can have a spike of glucose after the, and then it actually plummet down. So it's actually
lower than normal. And if they're not taking either blood glucose at a regular time each time
with a 12 hour fast, they could get some kind of false good glucose levels. We're actually
their glucose. On a 12 hour fast is raging in the hundreds, but they're getting false
glucose levels. Now that's not what this person is asking, but I just made that point because
hemoglobin A1C won't bounce up and down through the day. Hemoglobin A1C is a much better
lab value to look at to monitor diabetes than fasting glucose is. The reason why I want you to look
at fasting glucose is because it's easy to take, easy to do, easy to monitor at home, and easy to
monitor, easy to prevent those problems that I just mentioned, because you're going to take it every
morning right when you wake up. You have a 12 hour fast already. So you're going to have some
consistency of when you're taking it. You won't move your hemoglobin A1C or your insulin as fast.
So as you've changed your diet and you're keeping your fasting glucose at below 80 on a fairly
regular basis, the hemoglobin A1C and the insulin levels will follow. Understand the insulin levels are
also a function of your pancreas and your cell membranes as are your hemoglobin A1C. It takes time
to heal those. So you just have to be patient with your cell.